[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la hausse des prix du gaz et
d'électricité touchent directement au
moins 35 millions d'européens pour la
france plus question de fermer 14
réacteurs pourraient nuire à 50% la part
du nucléaire en 2035 l'allemagne est
dans une toute autre logique devenu club
du gaz russe en europe elle s'oppose à
la stratégie nucléaire de la france
mieux à est en crise tout cela c'est le
reflet en fait d'un conflit plus large
dont elle n'est que la proie est
aujourd'hui la victime
les français ont découvert une réalité
qui n'avait pas compris ou plutôt qu'on
ne leur avait pas expliqué
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter des grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce lundi 6 décembre
maintenant c'est le temps de l'unité un
appel lancé aujourd'hui par valérie
pécresse qui a passé la journée sur les
terres d'eric ciotti près de nice la
candidate heller à la présidentielle qui
promet aux finalistes de la primaire des
républicains une place singulière dans
sa campagne de son côté eric zemmour a
lancé hier son premier meeting en seine
saint denis un rendez-vous émaillées de
violence on connaît donc désormais les
affiches pour cette course à l'élysée
seul candidat non déclaré emmanuel
macron
vladimir poutine est un pays qu'il
considère comme une grande puissance le
deuxième déplacement du chef du kremlin
en dehors de la russie depuis le début
de la pandémie après son face à face
avec joe biden à genève en juin un
rendez vous avec le premier ministre
indien narendra modi qu'énonce ce soir
que les livraisons des systèmes russes
de défense antiaérienne s 400 a débuté
décryptage sur cette relation un d'horus
dans cette émission
un nouveau patient rentre en réanimation
toutes les 10 minutes c'est ce
qu'affirme ce soir olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé à moins de trois
semaines de noël la france prend de
nouvelles restrictions face à la
cinquième vague de qu'ovide les
discothèques seront à nouveau fermées
durant quatre semaines le protocole
sanitaire dans les écoles primaires
passe au niveau 3 c'est-à-dire masque en
intérieur mais aussi en extérieur pour
tout le monde le gouvernement envisage
d'ouvrir la vaccination contre le coguic
19 à tous les enfants de 5 à 11 ans sur
la base du volontariat si possible d'ici
la fin de l'année des mesures qu'on
décryptera dès 21h avec nos invités
et on s'intéressera aussi aux kovy de
long dont on parle très peu dans notre
rubrique qu'en pensent les français
n'oublieront ce soir à la rencontre de
virginie meyer qui souffre depuis déjà
plusieurs mois l avis de cette
auxiliaire de puéricultrice avec basculé
depuis qu'elle a été touchée par le
coronavirus lors de la première vague
elle ne peut plus travailler depuis un
an son témoignage poignant est à
retrouver dans la troisième partie de
cette émission
on connaît donc les candidats
officiellement lancer dans la course à
l'élysée seul candidat non déclaré
emmanuel macron alors qu'on est
maintenant à cinq mois de la
présidentielle on en parle tout de suite
avec notre journaliste d'arte et france
mélanie lepoutre qui nous a donc rejoint
sur ce plateau bonsoir mélanie et donc
l'image un politique de cette journée
mais dany à peine la primaire terminée
qu'on a suivi évidemment ainsi du mans
ce week-end la famille et l'eire qui est
rassemblée est le maître mot c'est unité
et soutien oui ce mot il a été répété
plusieurs fois aujourd'hui par valérie
pécresse et il y a une image qui ne
trompe pas regarder cette photo elle a
fait le tour des réseaux sociaux et des
médias aujourd'hui une photo entre
valérie pécresse et eric ciotti un qui
se sont vu toute la journée valérie
pécresse et eric ciotti qui ont déjeuné
en tête à tête cette image cette photo
du déjeuner elle a été diffusée par eric
ciotti sur son compte twitter qui a dit
être convaincu que valérie pécresse à
les remporter et bien l'élection
présidentielle les deux personnalités
donc je vous le disais ont passé la
journée ensemble dans le département des
alpes-maritimes eric ciotti est venu
chercher valérie pécresse tout à fait à
l'aéroport de ray de nice ils ont déposé
une gerbe à saint martin vésubie c'est
le village natal d'eric ciotti pour les
victimes de la tempête ici commence une
campagne d'espoir avec un pilier eric
ciotti valérie précresse voilà a promis
que le député des alpes-maritimes
allez jouer une place singulière dans sa
campagne il sera un pilier voilà ce
qu'elle a dit de quoi faire oublier en
tout cas les petites bisbilles du week
end après la victoire de valérie
pécresse au congrès dé des républicains
est la première déception de la campagne
puisque le grand meeting de républicains
qui devait se tenir dimanche à
versailles à paris a été annulée à cause
et bien tout simplement du risque
sanitaire lié à la cinquième vague du
coc vide et aujourd'hui on a bien
compris que si valérie pécresse voulait
faire campagne dans l'unité et avoir une
chance de l'emporter eh bien allez
devoir composer avec eric ciotti c'est
un allié un peu encombrant il a réalisé
quand même près de 40% des suffrages à
la primaire des républicains contre près
de 61% des voix pour valérie pécresse
elle ne peut pas s'en passer alors
message de rassemblement d'unité vous
venez de le décrire mélanie c'était la
tonalité de la journée aujourd'hui mais
vous parliez de bisbee à l'instant c'est
vrai que la première fausse note a eu
lieu samedi soir c'était sur le plateau
de nos confrères de tf1 première
interview officielle de la candidate les
républicains tout juste investi à la
question est ce que vous allez garder
certaines des propositions d'eric ciotti
valérie pécresse répond par la négative
regardez
voilà ce qu'est ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle indique que c'est manning qui
est une ligne qui peut permettre de
rassembler eric ciotti lui il a
immédiatement répliqué un le message
n'est pas le bon il a mis en garde
évidemment le député des alpes-maritimes
avertissements d'autant plus facile
qu'il ressort de cette primaire comme
l'homme fort des républicains que
valérie pécresse elle plafonne pour
l'instant autour des 10% d'intentions de
vote et que personne à droite ne veut
revivre l'épisode de la primaire 2016 où
les ténors du parti se font déchirer ce
déplacement de valérie pécresse vous
l'avez compris il avait donc toute son
importance aujourd'hui il fallait
rapidement des mines et pour ne pas
entacher l'unité retrouvée des
républicains et valérie pécresse même si
elle a gagné elle devait importer dégage
aujourd'hui montrer patte blanche et ce
soir d'ailleurs elle s'est dit prête à
reprendre des propositions d'eric ciotti
à leur passion à la sécurité 1 comme
elle l'a dit samedi soir mais sur
l'économie notamment sur la transmission
des patrimoines où eric ciotti veut une
exonération totale des successions et on
va justement par les uns dans quelques
instants avec nos deux invités un procès
aussi un pro pécresse ans dans quelques
instants décortiqué justement ces deux
visions de la droite aujourd'hui et
mélanie en attendant eric zemmour
lui tenait son premier grand meeting de
campagne air à villepinte étape on
combien importante pour lui la feuille
de route a semble-t-il était plutôt bien
rempli à part quelques anicroches dans
la salle la question c'est est ce que la
dynamique zemmour va reprendre à l'issue
de ce meeting et ça pour ça on verra les
résultats dans les prochaines vagues de
sondages là il est entre 12 et 13% alors
qu'il était à 20% pour certains
instituts et encore trois semaines il
était même qualifiée pour le second tour
ce qui est sûr c'est que le polémiste a
réussi son pari il a fait sa mue c'est
bien un candidat qu'on a vu hier à
villepinte reprenant d'ailleurs de
nombreux codes de nicolas sarkozy la
traversée de la foule pour atteindre le
podium il ya même eu une référence à son
fils mon papa on s'en souvient la salle
était remplie n'avait plus de dix mille
personnes avec différentes personnalités
d'ailleurs qu'on montrait leur
ralliement à sa candidature on a vu jean
frédéric poisson le président du parti
viac et l'ex parti chrétien démocrate ou
encore l'ex figure d gilet jaune
jacqueline moureaux c'est une véritable
opéra en tout cas qu'à lens eric zemmour
sur les électeurs républicains qui sont
encore indécis
pour lancer son parti qu'il a intitulé
reconquête en revanche il faut le dire
il n'a pas réussi à éviter tous les
pièges liés à l'organisation d'un tel
rassemblement plusieurs incidents ont
émaillé le meeting d'eric zemmour on
pense notamment aux équipes de
l'émission quotidien qui ont été
évacuées il ya une bagarre qui a été qui
a éclaté avec des militants de sos
racisme une scène très violente
un individu aussi tenter d'attraper reg
zemmour lors de son entrée dans la foule
l'homme est âgé de 27 ans il est déjà
connu pour des faits de droits communs
est toujours en garde à vue ce soir et
une enquête qui est ouverte également
pour la question que d'une jeune
militante de sos racisme voilà ça
entache un petit peu quand même ce
meeting alors de son côté eric zemmour
lui portent plainte puisqu'il a été
blessé au poignet une blessure qui est
bien entraîné une itt était de 9 jours
en tout cas depuis hier il dévoile lui
petit à petit son équipe de campagne et
ce soir on apprend notamment que c'est
le général bertrand de la chesnais qui a
été désigné comme son directeur de
campagne c'est un ex chasseurs
parachutistes de 63 cents proches du
rassemblement national jusqu'à présent
il est conseillé juste eric zemmour sur
les questions de défense mais merci
beaucoup ri n'est ni à lopou de
journalistes rt france pour ce point
complet sur l'actualité du week-end est
aussi évidemment de là on est puisque
c'était extrêmement importante vous
l'avez expliqué cette réunion ces
retrouvailles entre valérie pécresse et
eric sur tiago chant jean luc mélenchon
était également en meeting hier le
candidat de la france a soumis ce qu'ils
appellent à l'unité nationale contre les
idées de droite et d'extrême droite
antoine auger
[Musique]
la marseillaise qui résonne et les
drapeaux de la france qui s'agitent en
face de jean luc mélenchon à une
trentaine de kilomètres de villepinte où
se tenait le premier meeting d'eric
zemmour en vue de la présidentielle de
2000 22 le candidat de la france un
soumise à lui choisi l'arche de la
défense pour rassembler ses partisans et
mobiliser ses troupes contre l'avancée
du nationalisme en france nous venons
montrer au pays pour lui redonner du
courage alors qu'il est plongé dans
l'obscurité
deux des bars absurde où l'on voudrait
qu'ils se comptent l'un à l'autre pour
des affaires de religion ou de couleur
de peau nous venons dire est proclamée
grande fois de plus dont la france n'est
pas à l'extrême droite
la france c'est la sécurité sociale fait
la santé publique c'est l'émancipation
c'est l'école c'est la recherche par
tonne
en se présentant comme la principale
alternative à eric zemmour marine le pen
ou emmanuel macron la france insoumise
on appelle à l'unité dé gauche pour
faire gagner son candidat
françois soumises et très diverses mais
vous voyez bien qu'il fallait qu'on
aille plus loin et que des présidents
des associations comme attac par exemple
aurélie trouvé
du syndicat des avocats de france ou du
secours populaire des anciens présidents
rejoignent un parlement qui fait action
politique qui veut faire en sorte que le
candidat jean-françois élus pour nous
c'était absolument essentiel parfois
critiqué pour son manque de collégialité
dans ses décisions le parti entend
élargir ses soutiens si ils ne vont pas
voter c'est clair que la droite ou
d'extrême droite peut l'emporter mais si
demain il ya une mobilisation très large
et comme c'est souvent le cas d'ailleurs
dans des élections présidentielles alors
ces idées là peuvent l'emporter en avril
2 mai 22 parce qu'elles sont
majoritaires dans le pays et
qu'aujourd'hui elles et elles sont
incarnés par un collectif et c'est ce
collectif qui se présente alors qu entre
13 et 15 mille personnes sont venues
écouter eric zemmour près de 5000
partisans se sont déplacés pour soutenir
le candidat insoumis
crédité de 7,5 à 10 % des intentions de
vote dans les récents sondages jean luc
mélenchon qui brigue l'elysée pour la
troisième fois n'atteint pas pour le
moment les 20% d'électeurs comptabilisés
lors du premier tour de l'élection de
2017 des estimations bien loin derrière
les intentions de vote pour ceux contre
qui jean luc mélenchon se veut être le
principal opposant il comptabilise entre
25% pour le président sortant est plus
de 14% pour eric zemmour alors les
candidats de droite comme de gauche on
l'a vu sont tous ou presque dans les
starting blocks unité affichée à droite
derrière la candidate désignée valérie
pécresse qui affirme que la droite est
de retour alors est ce le cas la droite
est elle vraiment de retour comme
l'affirment sa représentante c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler philippe
bouyer sénateurs à l'ère des deux-sèvres
porte parole de valérie pécresse bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous philippe pouillé
à vos côtés à la joyandet sénateurs et
l'air de haute-saône soutien d'eric
ciotti ancien secrétaire d'état en
charge de la coopération et la
francophonie merci d'être avec nous
également bonsoir
alexis poulain qui nous accompagnent
éditorialistes d'ayrté france des dix
arbitres mais y'a rien à arbitrer à mon
cher alexis puisque cette journée a été
placée sous le signe d'une unité
parfaite on va on va en parler
maintenant d'ailleurs maintenant c'est
le temps de l'unité c'est ce que nous a
dit aujourd'hui valérie pécresse que je
vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
alors ce que je suis venu vous dire ici
pour rassurer tous ceux qui pourraient
s'inquiéter c'est que eric aura une
place très singulière dans ma campagne
parce qu'il a une voix très singulière à
faire entendre pour le pays
alors philippe mouillé on se demande un
petit peu ce que c'est cette expression
une place singulière parce qu'ils aient
une voix singulière qu'est vous le dire
valérie pécresse parce qu'on aurait pu
parler de place centrale non elle a
parlé de singulier c'est moi je crois
que c'est le thème qui a été démis
globalement l'idée c'est de dire que
dans ses copains littoral est il ce qui
a forcément à travers son projet et sa
personnalité un rôle essentiel dans la
campagne électorale alors on a pu dire
plein central là l'idée c'est vraiment
de mobiliser tous les acteurs mais la
foi traversions projet et surtout sa
façon d'être son positionnement alors dû
à travers les résultats aujourd'hui la
primaire eh bien il a un rôle essentiel
et la victoire se fera avec lui ça vous
convient cette expression
une place singulière parce qu'il a une
voix singulière vous êtes en phase avec
ces mots de valérie pécresse je crois
surtout que le message c'est celui de
l'unité certes mais c'est aussi de
le faire passer à une idée à la suite de
cette primaire l'idée selon laquelle le
rassemblement
peut-être selon valérie pécresse il
faudrait qu'on en sache un peu plus mais
en tout cas selon eric ciotti ce
rassemblement doit se faire à droite et
je pense que c'est ça la question qui
est posée c'est où est-ce qu'on se
rassemble comment est-ce qu'on se
rassemble pour gagner cette élection 40%
pour eric ciotti tout seuls
60% pour valérie pécresse qui fait une
très belle victoire
il y à une question qui se pose de
stratégie politique pour la campagne
électorale et je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
réponse en tout cas je l' ai compris
comme ça parce que c'est un peu
subliminal mais la réponse est celle là
il faut que ce rassemblement se fasse un
peu plus à droite qu'au centre pour
gagner cette élection alexis poulain on
va évidemment continuer à analyser parce
que elle est là la clé de l'enjeu
certainement est-ce qu'on va par la
droite par le centre c'est l'éternel
débat entre ces deux personnalités il
n'empêche eric ciotti 39% des mois qui
devient véritablement un faiseur de roi
ou de reine en l'occurrence oui plus que
ça je crois il montre l'évolution des
républicains depuis la présidence de
laurent wauquiez de toute façon est
clairement
aujourd'hui valérie pécresse ne peut pas
faire sans lui alors 7e place à part
elle reste à déterminer mais elle est
extrêmement important 40% seul c'est
plus que n'importe quel motion qu'on a
pu voir dans les partis de gauche on est
là sur vraiment un débat idéologique sur
ce que va être le vatel le programme des
républicains vont être les idées qu
est-ce qui va être débattu et le poids
parce qu'aujourd'hui effectivement il ya
une attente de la part des militants et
puis il ya un pays qui est la france
derrière et puis il ya des nouveaux
arrivants comme eric zemmour qui vont
capitaliser aussi sur lutte libre qu'il
a écrit depuis des années mais
clairement les républicains aujourd'hui
sur un tournant important et valérie
pécresse va devoir de toute façon se
démarquer stratégiquement clairement
d'emmanuel macron parce que il y à des
mesures des ménages macron qui sont
clairement fait pour empêcher embêter le
camp républicain donc elle pourra
compter sur l'ex yotive pour justement
avoir cette base idéologique très
différente du maquereau nisme et de la
maison commune qui est ce nouveau centre
qui est construit par edouard philippe
françois bayrou et les autres philippe
maillet vous êtes d'accord vous avec
justement ce diagnostic d'eric ciotti la
victoire se fera à la droite parce qu'on
sent que valérie pécresse quand même
voilà dix ans ce week-end noël ne veut
pas dénaturer son programme on se
souvient quand même d'une valérie
pécresse on en parle peu de l'enfant en
2017 et a claqué la porte dlr parce
qu'elle trouvait que la ligne de vaud
qui était beaucoup trop doux droitière à
ce qu'on peut faire confiance quand on
est un proche d'eric ciotti pour être
représenté dans le programme de valérie
pécresse clairement non je crois que
d'abord il ya un message qui est très
clair c'est qu'on sait que pour gagner
il faut être unis et on voit bien que
par rapport à 2010 est la france se
droitise vomir à travers à la fois les
les expressions politiques et la rue
voilà donc la ligne politique elle est
forcément rassemblés sur un
positionnement qui celui qui était donné
par la primaire dont la production de
droite claque reçue il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté et le message qui a été
portée aujourd'hui les aussi une soute
segura était pour moi laissez
l'expression avant tout à sa part et
donc c'est pas mal à travers notamment
des jours qui viennent et la finalité
des programmes on va pouvoir travailler
justement sur ces lignes politiques et
voulaient être humain dit on a besoin
clairement aujourd'hui de parler elle
est notre électorat qui revendiquent des
idées claires de droite et en même temps
on a besoin de se démarquer par rapport
au positionnement et bien des macros
avec 102 mesures voilà donc là-dessus il
n'y a pas d'ambiguïté le tout c'est que
malgré tout ça il faut aussi rassembler
le plus large possible donc c'est la
fois avoir un positionnement clairement
à droite et en même temps est bien
certain nombre de propositions qui
élargissent encore la base qui sera
nécessaire parce que c'est 50 % plus une
alain joyandet aller où la limite entre
rassembler et
épouse est vraiment une ligne de droite
et de droite forte peut-être un élément
technique politique pour illustrer ma
réponse la sondage est sorti aujourd'hui
sondage ifop si je peux me permettre de
le solliciter
ou d'un seul coup valérie pécresse passe
à 17% d'intentions de vote dans les
sondages
déjà ça veut dire que la primaire des
républicains comme nous l'espérions fait
que son champion bénéficie d'un effet de
levier après le résultat ça c'est une
première chose dans ce sondage il y à
valérie pécresse il n'y a pas de de deux
personnalités centristes qui soit mesuré
donc lé sol pour la droite et le centre
et l'est à 17% à égalité avec marine le
pen devant monsieur zemmour et au
deuxième tour dans la marge d'erreur
avec emmanuel macron ce qui veut dire
c'est un grand espoir pour les
républicains mais pour répondre à la
question rien emmanuel macron si je peux
me permettre au centre quand même bien
sûr mais c'est pour ça que je dis que
elle est mesurée au deuxième tour avec
emmanuel macron dans la marge d'erreur
on est à 52 48 et au premier tour elle
est à égalité avec madame le pen donc
prête à se qualifier pour le deuxième
tour et par rapport à ce que je disais
au début le fait qu'elle soit seule
candidate mesuré pour la droite et le
sang les points qui lui manquent
arithmétiquement en tout cas si
j'analyse ce sondage comme cela les
points qui lui manquent il faut qu'elles
les prennent où il faut qu'elles les
prennent à droite il faut qu'elle ait
pris il faut qu'il y ait des électeurs
qui nous ont quittés par déception qui
sont partis chez madame le pen ou qui
sont séduits par monsieur zemmour il
faut qu on en récupère une partie pour
faire en sorte qu'on soit qualifié ou au
premier tour après le premier tour pour
le deuxième tour je rappelle je vais lui
c'est un peu une évidence mais enfin
rappelons le pour gagner le deuxième
tour il faut se qualifier c'est à dire
qu'il faut au moins deuxième lors du
premier tour d'où cette analyse mais qui
n'est pas du tout en contradiction avec
ce que vient de dire mon ami philippe
rouyer mais c'est un vrai débat c'est de
vous poser vraiment la bonne question
c'est où est ce qu'on met le curseur et
où est-ce qu'on fait le rassemblement
moi j'apporte cette réponse peut-être
que j'ai vu le sourire quand même
aujourd'hui
d'eric ciotti et de valérie pécresse
j'imagine qu'ils aient un certain nombre
de choses qui se sont dites qui qui
permettent d'avoir ce sourire et donc
d'être d'accord sur la ligne quant à la
place d'eric ciotti dans la campagne
électorale je pense qu'on sera bientôt
alexis pour l'un j'en reviens sur ce que
je disais une valérie pécresse qu'on
présente souvent comme centriste même
potentiellement un maquereau compatibles
on l'a répété tant de fois aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous en tant qu'analyste
politique vous la sentez prête cette
candidate républicaine à aller vers la
droite d'eric ciotti
et comment placer le curseur pour elle
oui on l'a vu déjà lors des débats de la
primaire pour le congrès elle a déjà
déplacé le curseur après il ya un
problème bien sûr de débilité celle qui
a quitté le parti parce que pour elle
laurent wauquiez était trop bas à droite
ça pose un problème maintenant de
revenir et d'incarner cette ligne de
droite qui est hégémonique donc il va
falloir qu'elle incarne cette taille là
qu'est le qu'elles prennent en
crédibilité quel travail du coup avec
eric ciotti évidemment donc on a là
peut-être à faire à un exécutif
bicéphale au sein du parti une campagne
qui va se jouer à deux et pas seulement
avec valérie pécresse il va pouvoir
jouer sur toutes les nuances de
républicanisme c'est l'idée sans doute
la façon dont ça va s'organiser pour
elle il ya tout un chemin à faire parce
que les électeurs préféreront toujours
l'original à la copie et je vois mal des
électeurs séduits par eric zemmour
choisir et une fille née de voter
valérie pécresse à la fin ou des
électeurs aujourd'hui
supporters des modèles macron qui irait
voir madame pécresse à la suite donc
c'est un chantier herculéen il ya
beaucoup de travail pour convaincre mais
pour ça il faut un travail d'équipé et
je pense qu'eric ciotti est une pièce
majeure dans ce travail de reconquête de
la droite de la droite en tout cas la
question de savoir si la droite est de
retour on va on va se tourner vers ses
premiers messages télégramme pécresse
égale juppé galles sarkozy galles chirac
la pseudo droite kobe à la gauche pour
ceux qui n'auraient pas encore compris
le seul absoudre ou droite en france est
une idéologie centriste européaniste
comme macron d'ailleurs quant à paul il
dit la droite quelle droite celle de
pécresse et celle de chirac ou sarkozy
soumise à la gauche pourquoi car ils
sont d'accord pour dire une chose le
danger c'est l'extrême droite cqfd ils
font campagne l extrême droite et
gouverne au centre je ne leur ferai plus
jamais confiance ça c'est vrai que
philippe bouillet il faut l'entendre ce
côté voilà c'est un peu tiède c'est un
peu ou un peu illisible vous réfutez
aujourd'hui ces critiques oui tout est
fait je crois que on est dans une autre
compagnie littoral on est aujourd'hui
face à une situation où la france a
évolué à mon avis plus favorablement et
que les réponses qui sont attendus
réponse qui doit être ferme et à la fois
humaniste c'est vraiment le pilier et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on l'a bien vu à
travers la campagne des primaires moi
j'ai tourné tout d'abord
entendre on l'évoqué le fait du départ
de valérie pécresse c'est plus le sujet
on a le résultat aujourd'hui elle a été
placée en tête et on voit que la ligne
parce que parce que la relation avec les
républicains a changé c'est plutôt et
brumath qu à terme et auront bien
qu'aujourd'hui à la fois l'été
positionne en tête et que la ligne
portée patriotique est clair aussi a été
repris comme étant la deuxième
alternative donc tout doit être
construit autour de se gérer de ces
idées là et puis en même temps c'est une
équipe c'est une équipe de faucon en
construire on parle forcément des 2 2
qui sont arrivés au second tour on a
besoin aussi de tout le monde tous les
tubes à la fois de leurs veaux kim
également
déserté me chalié on a besoin d'avoir
une équipe pour montrer qu'à un moment
donné et bien c'est une volonté
collective de trouver une solution
alternative pour la france et à partir
de là dès lors qu'on est sur une
capacité de réellement dire ce qu'on va
faire et donner de la crédibilité
j'écris vite est à la fois sur la ligne
politique c'est une crime étaient
également travers l'expérience des uns
des autres et choc là on a vraiment les
clés de la réussite clairement quels
sont les thèmes qui ont fâché le pue ça
on a parlé beaucoup d'immigration
d'islamisme on va parler d'économie
aussi mais qu'elles sont au sein des
proches d'eric ciotti les plus grandes
craintes si j'ose dire quelles sont les
propositions sur lesquelles vous ne
dérangerait pas du côté surtout si vous
en avez évidemment la possibilité de ne
pas y déroger je crois d'abord si on
veut rassembler
aucun des candidats papus valérie
pécresse que eric ciotti ne peut dire ça
sera mon programme tout mon programme
rien que mon programme et je prends rien
d autre donc il faut bien trouver à un
moment donné il faut trouver la crête il
faut trouver la ligne rouge je crois que
sur les sujets régaliens qui touche qui
touche à l'immigration qui touche à
l'identité nationale qui touche à la
sécurité
je pense que tous les deux
ont trouvé un terrain d'entente alors
évidemment il ya quelques totem il ya
quelques totem comme par exemple la
question du droit du sol ou du droit du
sang on va pas forcément demandé à
valérie pécresse de reprendre à son
compte cette proposition mais quand on
parle de des propositions de valérie
pécresse est pas forcément un mois de de
l'est de l'est comment dire de les
revendiquer puisque moi je soutenais
eric ciotti mais aujourd'hui je soutient
valérie pécresse donc je vais pas
commencer à dire c'est ça ou rien et je
pense pas qu eric ciotti les 10 c'est ça
ou rien je pense qu'eric ciotti a raison
dans l'intérêt de valérie pécresse dans
l'intérêt de notre famille politique de
vouloir bien crantée un certain nombre
de propositions à minima sur les sujets
que je vient d'élaborer mais mais mais
il ya autre chose il ya l'économie ou
désir
de regarder les différences passées en
tout cas sur les grandes questions qui
touchent à l'immigration on a bien vu
pendant cette campagne j'en termine jean
terreïs pour dire que les deux projets
les deux projets d'ailleurs c'est à
noter sur les cinq candidats les deux
projets qui étaient le plus à droite
c'était justement les deux projets
d'eric ciotti et de valérie pécresse et
ils sont arrivés en tête ça veut dire
quelque chose il faut bien penser à cela
regardez ouais c'est ces convergences et
des divergences sur l'immigration fin de
l'aide médicale d'état sauf urgence
supprimer les aides sociales aux
sans-papiers prestations sociales 1
conditionnée à une durée de résidence
sur le territoire ont en commun les deux
candidats divergences sur l'immigration
des quotas par métier par pays fin du
droit du sol automatique et priorités
nationales pour les emplois restaurer le
droit du sang supprimant le droit du sol
philippe mouillé c'est ce sont des
propositions ça qu'ils sont qui son
intuition elle a évoqué justement le
débat ce droit du sol voilà on voit bien
qu on va devoir faire agir est une union
a très bien déjà les bases communes et
puis ensuite on va discuter parfois
points pour avoir d'autres
positionnement voilà mais aujourd'hui
les débats sur la table mais surtout ce
que le plus important c'est ce qui nous
rassemble que plus fondamental les plus
importants donc ça veut dire qu'à partir
de là eh bien on doit construire un
projet reprenant et bien des dépositions
demandez un des autres pour trouver la
meilleure synthèse voilà donc
appartenant ou alors on parle pas vous
évoquez la fin de la discussion dans
tous les cas le sujet sur la table et
c'était parti des démarches c'est vrai
pour les thématiques évoquées c'est
vraiment domaine de l'économie on a
quand même beaucoup de sujets en matière
de réformes parlant de l'état les
chiffres varient mais la volonté commune
de réformer l'état est identique chez
les deux candidats on voit bien
aujourd'hui les points communs sont
largement plus important que le reste
alexis blanc c'est vrai ça en tant
qu'observateur les points communs sont
plus importants que les divergences
entre les candidats c'est aussi votre
votre analyse oui on a vu d'ailleurs
durant tous les débats pour le prendre
la tête et avoir la candidature à
l'issue de ce congrès les il y avait une
volonté de chercher les convergences du
toqué divergences de montrer l'union
dans du camp républicain compte tenu de
ce qu'on a en face à où la gauche est
totalement immunité donc là il ya une
stratégie globale du parti qui est celle
de l'unité de montrer qu'il ya une
équipe qui est prête à gouverner qui est
prête à s'entendre maintenant évidemment
les tractations les divergences et elles
vont pas être montrée en public au grand
jour il y aura sans doute beaucoup de
travail en équipe pour arriver à un
programme commun ça s'appelle la
synthèse ça se fait dans les grands
partis et ça va être fait dans les
semaines qui viennent dans les mois qui
viennent pour présenter un programme
cohérent avec bien sûr la prise en
compte de cette droitisation à la fois
de l'électorat et aussi du programme
d'aidé républicain et puis peut-être le
retour du court mais lestée de laurent
wauquiez d'une certaine façon puisque
lui et est parti par la petite porte
lorsqu'il était président et là on voit
que des années après ces années c'est
l'idée ont gagné et qu'on arrive à
débattre sur cette base programmatique
donc c'est quand même un pas important
vers une sorte de républicains 2.0 alors
droitisation évidemment sur ces
questions régaliennes immigration
question aussi de l'identité de
l'islamisme est aussi vous avez commencé
en parlais tout à l'heure ce joyandet le
projet économiquement ça m'a un petit
peu frappés parce que c'est vrai qu'on
n'en parle peut-être un petit peu moins
enfin il est des différences majeures
bon suppression des d'un certain nombre
de fonctionnaires côté pécresse mais
enfin surtout cet impôt sur le revenu à
15% pour eric ciotti alors que valérie
pécresse halal veut donner un coup de
pouce à des salaires qui vont jusqu'à
3500 euros parce qu'elle souhaitait
augmenter de 10% en baissant les charges
sociales pas du tout la même ligne 1 sur
l' on est déjà là on est déjà dans
l'application des mesures donc j'allais
dire que ça change beaucoup de choses
pour beaucoup de français j'allais dire
justement une chose c'est que pour les
français le plus important on a parlé
beaucoup des questions identitaires mais
pour les français la question c'est
quand même comment j'améliore mes
conditions de vie aujourd'hui on a des
français qui travaillent et bien qu'il
travaille qui ne s'en sortent plus avec
des charges sociales qui sont absolument
écrasante et la question du financement
du travail et de d2 de le travailler
plus pour travailler plus travailler
plus pour gagner plus pardon c'est
toujours vrai et c'est toujours ce que
les français attendent on voit bien que
les deux candidats sur ces questions là
sont quand même plus outre ou d'accord
parce que la grande question qui
concerne les finances publiques c'est et
les finances sociales ou au sens large
si si on ne réduit pas les charges de
l'état personne ne pourra améliorer la
situation des français sur ce sujet
fondamental
eric ciotti valérie pécresse qui baisse
les charges de l'état pour redonner cet
argent en rémunération du travail c'est
quand même l'essentiel est là dessus ils
sont d'accord alors après la flat tax ou
faire autrement évidemment ce sont des
ce sont des choses qui qui sont
différentes mais je pense que là encore
il y aura quelque chose à trouver pour
baisser massivement les impôts financent
et cela par la réduction de la dépense
publique pour redonner en rémunération
du travail des français je crois que
là-dessus c'est quand même l'essentiel
ils sont d'accord oui je dirai oui
il ya une logique de baisse des impôts
ça c'était pas les trois principaux
évoqués là c'est le train de vie de
l'état c'est la baisse des impôts vous
discutera à quel niveau quelles sont les
priorités et puis un moment donné
comment on
donne notamment à ceux qui ont plus
besoin à bord en france aujourd'hui des
travailleurs pauvres c'est pato nattes
des gens qui se mobilisent qui
travaillent il faut trouver des
solutions l'ail et des pistes qui sont
sur la table on va les affiner mais le
principe général cat est décrit par
alain est exactement le principe qui est
porté par des candidats qui sera portée
dans notre vie politique alexis poulain
le mot de la fin pour vous justement sur
cette question économique ce pouvoir
d'achat très attendu puisque c'est la
préoccupation principale aujourd'hui des
des français dans cette campagne
oui clairement pouvoir d'achat qui fait
invité à la dernière minute dans cette
campagne est menée le mac on ne comptait
pas du tout faire campagne sur ce thème
et son bilan est bien maigre en matière
de pouvoir d'achat donc là il va falloir
proposer et il ya bien sûr rendre
l'emploi ratera ctif créer davantage
d'emplois la baisse des impôts c'est à
peu près dans tous les programmes pour
pâques mais les français sont attachés
aussi à leur modèle social donc il faut
ménager la chèvre est toujours le voir
avec la crise de l'hôpital il faut faire
extrêmement attention peut-être qu'il y
a des services publics prioritaires à
mettre en avant et d'autres à repenser
et puis il ya bien sûr une nouvelle
imposition du 21e siècle a cherché avec
gabegie dans les dépenses publiques ce
n'est pas nouveau c'est la france a un
taux d'imposition énorme et pourtant
dans l'impression que les services
publics ne sont pas à la auteur donc il
ya un vrai problème ce problème là bas
c'est le sait peut-être plus d'un
quinquennat qu'il faudrait pour s'y
atteler mais clairement il va falloir
régler ce problème du pouvoir d'achat
compliqué parce que par exemple
l'énergie ça ne peut pas se régler
rapidement si on veut construire de
nouvelles centrales avoir de l'éolien un
mix énergétique qui fait qu'on va
pouvoir baisser le prix et plusieurs
années là encore d'investissement est
tout tout est un peu pareil sur tous les
dossiers donc il va falloir trouver une
solution et elle n'est pas forcément
évidente c'est sûr merci ça sera deux
mois de la fin en tout cas merci alexis
pour la merci à vous deux philippe
houllier alain joyandet d'avoir été avec
le passé sur le plateau d'ayrté france
merci à vous
emmanuel macron a conclu avec les
émirats arabes unis un contrat record de
vente de rafale l'iran accuse la france
de déstabiliser la région en vendant des
armes à ses rivaux du golfe la france
contribue à la militarisation et
favorise les troupes dans la région
selon le porte parole du ministre
iranien des affaires étrangères
il a également rejeté les demandes de la
france d'associer les pays de la région
pour avancer dans les discussions autour
du dossier du nucléaire iranien et ses
déclarations interviennent au moment
donc où le conseiller émirati à la
sécurité nationale est à téhéran pour
rencontrer les responsables iraniens une
rencontre exceptionnelle et entre de
hauts responsables de chaque pays après
50 ans y ont la nécessité de rétablir le
dialogue entre téhéran et le chef dé
file des monarchies du golfe depuis
2016 l'arabie saoudite yamina benguigui
c'est une image des plus inhabituels
depuis la rupture de leurs relations
diplomatiques en 2016 un haut
responsable émirati cheikh tamim bin
zayed conseiller à la sécurité nationale
et ebrahim raïssi président iranien
autour de la même table l'iran et
l'arabie saoudite ont vu leurs relations
diplomatiques se détériorer suite à
l'assassinât par ryad d'un influent
opposant religieux chiites aujourd'hui
cette première rencontre est motivée par
l'urgence de rétablir les relations
bilatérales dans une région où s'exerce
de fortes polarité de bonnes relations
avec les pays de la région sont l'une
des priorités de la politique étrangère
du nouveau gouvernement et nous saluons
ainsi le développement des relations
avec les émirats arabes unis une
nouvelle page dans les relations entre
les deux états salué par le représentant
du conseil suprême iranien monsieur chat
marani a exprimé l'espoir que la visite
de son homologue émirati soit le début
d'une nouvelle page dans les relations
entre les deux pays et ouvre la voie à
la consolidation et à l'expansion des
relations bilatérales un objectif
partagé par les deux états les émirats
arabes unis cherchent à renforcer la
stabilité et la prospérité régionales en
développant des relations positives par
le dialogue en s'appuyant sur les points
communs et en gérant les visions
divergentes un rebond diplomatique qui
permettrait à la république islamique
d'iran d'améliorer ses échanges avec les
pays voisins
téhéran est en effet accusé malgré ses
démentis de chercher à développer l'armé
atomique et de déstabiliser la région en
pacifiant ces relations l'iran espère
atténuer les inquiétudes générées contre
elle alors même qu'elle est entré dans
un nouveau cycle de négociations sur le
dossier nucléaire
le président russe est en visite en inde
aujourd'hui il est accompagné de ses
ministres de la défense et des affaires
étrangères un mini sommet entre moscou
et new delhi pour renforcer les liens
militaires et énergétiques un
déplacement aux rares à l'étranger pour
le chef du kremlin son deuxième
seulement depuis le début de la pandémie
ont fait le point avec notre
correspondante à moscou vera goffman
l'énergie la défense et la coopération
dans le domaine de l'espace au coeur des
pourparlers du président russe vladimir
poutine et le premier ministre indien
narendra modi le dirigeant russe se
déplace ce lundi dans la soirée à new
delhi pour une visite de travail prévue
de longue date mais repoussé à cause de
la pandémie de coronavirus un échange
d'une grande importance pour les deux
chefs d'état selon iouri ouchakov
conseiller du président la rencontre se
tiendra un format tête à tête des
accords doivent être également signé à
lors de cette rencontre écoutez on
coopère dans divers secteurs dans divers
domaines dont l'énergie nucléaire et
l'espace en témoigne la dizaine
d'accords bilatéraux assez importants y
compris des accords semi-fermée qui ont
été préparés seront signés pour la
visite les parties continuent à
travailler sur ces accords nous sommes
convaincus que l'ensemble des accords
sera formalisée dans le cadre de la
visite une commission russo indienne sur
la coopération militaire se réunira
également new delhi en présence du
ministre russe de la défense sergueï
choïgou et son homologue indien elle
sera suivie d'une rencontre entre les
chefs de la diplomatie et de la défense
des deux pays la visite de vladimir
poutine intervient alors que la russie a
commencé la livraison à l'inde de
systèmes de défense antiaérienne s 400
triumph la première unité doit être
livré d'ici la fin d'année la russie et
l'inde ont signé un contrat pour cinq
complexes s-400 en octobre 2018 pour un
montant de 5,4 milliards de dollars et
on va plus loin avec régis sommer grand
reporter pour rt france bonsoir régis
merci de nous avoir rejoint la russie
dont sont des amis proches depuis des
dizaines d'années mais plus que jamais
moscou comme new delhi valeur renforcer
leurs liens pourquoi ce besoin
aujourd'hui je rassurais mutuellement
voyez plusieurs raisons d'ailleurs la
visite de vladimir poutine est très
symbolique ça a été elle est symbolique
elle est forte de sens pourquoi parce
que d'abord c'est la deuxième visite
depuis le début de la pandémie et
n'oublions pas aussi qu'il n'a pas été
présent au g20 il n'a pas été prévu
faisant non plus à la coop 26 mai ce
déplacement élite n'est est né à
réaffirmer justement ce partenariat fort
on dit évidemment il ya des des
commandes des dizaines d'années de deux
pas de partenariat pas oublier que la
l'urss à l'époque delà donc de la russie
soviétique était là la puissance
tutélaire de l'un d'eux même si l'inde
et évasée partie avec nehru des non
alignés néanmoins elle n'a pas de
plonger dans le camp dans le camp
occidental comme le voulaient les états
unis à l'époque du coup les etats-unis
ont renforcé progressivement leur
partenariat avec le pakistan et on sait
que l'inde et le pakistan biens sont à
couteaux tirés la donne a beaucoup
changé aussi avec l'afghanistan un pas
oublié ce ce cet événement important par
le fait justement que les pakistanais
évidemment un oeil aux pâquis en
afghanistan et que longtemps l'inde et
le pakistan se sont fait véritablement
une guerre larvée ou tours justement de
leur présence et de leur influence en
afghanistan donc il ya une nouvelle
donne afghane ya aussi également un
problème aussi au niveau des ventes
d'armes
historiquement les armes étaient
évidemment fourni par la russie vendu
par la russie aujourd'hui la part des
ventes et des commandes est tombé en
dessous de 50%
la france a fait de l'inde son deuxième
partenaire économique en termes de
ventes d'armes l'europe est également
présente et les etats unis aussi
comment vladimir poutine est venu pour
réaffirmer dans ce secteur des nouvelles
coopérations et à une une signature d'un
contrat de 750 mille armes à 4,203 comme
des noues des nouveaux fusils d'assaut
et également pour vendre les fameux
es400 qui sont les missiles de croisière
souvenait que les états unis sont égales
la russie a également vendu à la turquie
avec ses menaces de sanctions
américaines puisque ce sont des armes a
dit stick et donc voilà donc il ya
réaffirmant rats firmament de de cette
coopération dans le domaine des arts
mais également aussi dans le domaine de
la santé puisque on sait que le spoutnik
le vaccin russe va être produit en inde
massivement 300 millions de doses vont
être voilà donc il ya
une importance considérable entre ces
deux pays réaffirmer cette coopération
la question afghane évidemment a changé
la donne et la russie éprouve le besoin
justement de se renforcer dans en asie
centrale alors régis vous restez avec
nous je vous propose en main puisque on
va évoquer un autre thème d'actualité
puisque vladimir poutine un agenda très
chargé cette semaine le président russe
qui s'entretiendra demain en visio
conférence avec son homologue américain
l émir poutine et joe biden qui ne se
sont pas parlés en depuis juillet
dernier l'enjeu est donc de taille les
précisions de notre correspondant
antoine frérot a moscou
les deux présidents vont se parler en
visioconférence ce mardi dans la soirée
et sans surprise il sera question de
l'ukraine le dossier brûlant de
l'actualité en effet washington accuse
moscou d'amasser des troupes à sa
frontière dans l'optique d'une attaque
ce que les autorités russes démentent
tout en évoquant des provocations de la
part de l'otan qui multiplient les
opérations en mer noire même si le
dialogue reste difficile entre les deux
hommes les accords conclus lors du
sommet de genève pourrait servir de base
à ces négociations
bien sûr il faudrait examiner comment
les accords conclus à genève sont mises
en oeuvre voir ce qu'ils réaliser
pleinement et ce qui exigera des efforts
supplémentaires
puis certainement les relations
bilatérales dont l'état est toujours
pitoyable
et aussi je crois les questions à
l'ordre du jour avant tout les tensions
autour de l'ukraine
l'extension de l'otan en direction de
nos frontières l'initiative du président
poutine concernant les garanties de
sécurité
tous ces sujets seront discutées
la situation en ukraine et c'est
possible le développement seront au
coeur de ces discussions en particulier
l'établissement de lignes rouges d'un
côté comme de l'autre mais joe biden et
vladimir poutine devrait également
évoquer d'autres thématiques comme le
contrôle des armements nucléaires dans
une discussion qui devrait durer un
certain temps régis le sommier vous êtes
toujours avec nous les relations russo
américaines qui connaissent une nouvelle
dégradation viens d'en parler cet
entretien baydan poutine c'est un pas
vers l'apaisement devant vous alors un
pas vers un pas vers l'apaisement c'est
difficile de dire en tout cas il a le
mérite d'exister on sait qu'il a eu lieu
en présentiel en juin dernier les deux
hommes voilà ce son voile à ça a été
tendu mais ça mais il faut pas oublier
qu'avant il n'y avait que comment le
général miley le général guère asimov
qui se parlaient c'est à dire on parler
qu'entre militaire là il ya quand même
donc le pouvoir politique qui reprend le
dessus il ya un dialogue et une volonté
peut-être d'apaiser les tensions les
russes ont fait entendre que en
minimiser on dit voilà nous n'espérons
pas une baisse des tensions et grand
chose de ce 2 de ce commentaire de cette
rencontre donc par visioconférence
normand il faut quand même reconnaître
une chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui ces
tensions elles sont réelles entre les
lacs tensions autour de l'ukraine à est
réelle elle est réelle pourquoi parce
que il ya eu d'abord un armement l'armée
ukrainienne a été modernisée a été armée
par les états unis notamment qui lui ont
fourni des missiles anti tant que des
missiles guidés en titans qui s'appelle
des diables in également l'armée
ukrainienne dispose aujourd'hui de
commandes de drones turc bayrac tarbes
et tv2 qui sont on s'en souvient à
l'époque du de la guerre au karabagh qui
ont fait des ravages sur les tanks
arméniens qui veut et l époque utilisés
par l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
donc ça c'était d'aider c'est une forme
de modernisation et on a remarqué que du
côté russe les tanks russes avaient été
équipées pour justement faire face
maintenant à cette menace donc il ya une
sorte de réciprocité qui se fait et ça
se fait au niveau militaire au niveau du
terrain donc ça c'est important ensuite
ce qu'on peut remarquer c'est que donc
voilà oui on pourra dire que plus tard
les la russie est là et les etats unis
se reparle c'est une forme de confort
quelque part pourquoi c'est une forme de
confort parce que la génération de joe
biden comme la génération de vladimir
poutine ce sont quelque part je vais
dire ça de façon un peu caricaturale
mais des orphelins de la guerre froide
c'est à dire ce qu'ils ont ils ont été
nourris justement de cette adversité
entre russes et américains il ya aux
états unis encore aujourd'hui et on
réussit aussi aujourd'hui des gens qui
pensent que cet affrontement comment est
toujours prévu prévaut même si
idéologiquement les choses ont changé
même si le marxisme aujourd'hui comment
a disparu du côté russe et que la
société américaine également inchangé
mais il ya quand même encore tous est
cette idée que on peut voilà
l'adversaire c'est ta l'est et pour les
russes adversaire c'est ça reste des
états unis regardez les image en vous
parlant on et on espère que ça sera un
peu plus chaleureux que les d'un enfant
non je ne respirait pas la franche
rigolade entre les protagonistes à
chacun de leur secrétaire oui mais
souvenez-vous de ce qu'avait dit joe
biden à propos de vladimir poutine il
l'avait tuée de il avait le qualifier de
tueur donc voilà donc les môles escalade
verbale était allée très loin néanmoins
la rencontre a eu lieu là on est on est
dans une forme de nouveau téléphone
rouge puisqu'il ya eu une escalade ça se
paye pas sans vision conférence on est
au 21ème siècle voilà donc là il ya un
dialogue qui s'établit et je dirais que
ça ne veut pas dire qu'aujourd'hui on
est au bord de la guerre le dessin est
ce qu'il faut aux relevés régis un point
important qui nous a pas échappé c'est
que le dialogue se fait sans l'europe 1
qui pourtant est consacrée concerné
pleinement houdart ce dossier ukrainien
c'est sûr sans se mettre totalement
alors en fait le problème c'est que ni
pour les états unis ni pour la russie
l'europe ne représente 1 intègre un
interlocuteur cohérent on sait que voilà
les états unis préfèrent
miser sur l'allemagne ça a été dit de
façon et l'europe en tant que telle
n'est pas considéré comme un
interlocuteur pourquoi parce que il ya
l'otan et donc les etats-unis
considèrent que voilà le lac ce de
défense et est inscrit au tour de l'otan
l'armée européenne en tant que tel
n'existe pas même si elle est ajoutée
agitées régulièrement on en parle
l'europe de la défense mais finalement
ce sont des mots donc les etats-unis
considèrent que voilà ils ont un
interlocuteur c'est l'otan qui vient peu
leur bras armé avancé et que la
puissance financière et celle qui est
capable de débloquer des choses pour eux
c'est l'allemagne l'allemagne qui joue
d'ailleurs de cette puissance puisque
dans le cadre des accords de nord stream
2 a fait cet accord du justement de
gazoduc avec la russie donc elle peut se
permettre de parler avec les deux donc
lieu d'une certaine façon voilà c'est
simplifier au niveau européen c'est
compliqué où ça n'existe pas du coup les
européens soient un petit peu laissé à
côté de ce set 7 ce second affrontement
en tout cas cette cette donne
géopolitique nouvelle entre la russie et
les etats unis on en parlera évidemment
longuement à demain avec cet entretien
entre les deux hommes merci à vous si
c'est le sommier nous avoir apporté
votre décryptage
la peine d'un saint soufi réduite à deux
ans de prison annonce aujourd'hui du
chef de la junte militaire en birmanie
initialement l'ex dirigeante avait écopé
de quatre ans de prison pour incitation
aux troubles publics et violation des
règles sanitaires liés aux qu'ovide
cette réduction censure intervient après
les nombreuses condamnations à
l'international du verdict le comité du
prix nobel de la paix se dit inquiet les
etats-unis dénoncent eux un affront à la
justice alors que l'union européenne et
la haute commissaire aux droits de
l'homme des nations unies évoquent eux
un verdict politiquement motivé
la haute commissaire des nations unies
aux droits de l'homme et michelle
bachelet déplore vivement la
condamnation de la conseillère d'état du
myanmar octobre succi à l'issue d'un
simulacre de procès devant un tribunal
contrôlée par l'armée au mépris des
normes internationales d'équité la
condamnation d'aung san suu kyi ne fera
qu'accentuer le rejet des règles de
l'art mais la haute commissaire s'est
dit préoccupé par le fait que ces
développements risquent d'exacerber
davantage les tensions et la violence au
myanmar
de son côté londres dénonce une
tentative d'étouffer l'opposition pour
rappel and sand soutien est assigné à
résidence depuis le coup d'état
militaire du 1er février dernier retour
en images sur les accusations visant
actuellement en birmanie le prix nobel
de la paix
[Musique]
en
on
[Musique]
en tunisie le parti ennahdha première
formation politique du pays a tenu ce
matin une conférence de presse
l'occasion pour son bureau exécutif de
revenir sur certaines accusations dont
fait l'objet le parti tout en invitant
le chef de l'état une reprise du
dialogue le point avec notre
correspondant à tunis d'un seul chez lui
après des semaines de silence le parti
ennahdha formation politique
conservatrice et islamiste soutenu par
une majorité des tunisiens lors des
élections législatives de 2009 enfin
prié la parole devant un parterre de
journalistes alors que la presse
attendait l'exposé du programme
d'ennahdha en pleine crise politique et
les membres du bureau exécutif ont
transformé cette conférence de presse en
un véritable plaidoyer le but se
dédouaner de toutes les accusations qui
circulent depuis des mois sur le clan de
rached ghannouchi le chef de file est
président du parlement gelés pour les
membres du parti il s'agit bel et bien
d'une tentative d'écarter le parti de la
scène politique tunisienne par le chef
de l'état a payé side ils se sont
plaints à d'être présentée depuis
quelques mois comme responsable de tous
les maux économiques et sociaux du pays
et ont martelé que sans une reprise
effective du dialogue avec le président
de la république rien ne pourra relever
la tunisie de cette crise écouter
aujourd'hui nous pouvons supporter
toutes les pressions et difficulté et on
assume nos erreurs mais de là à assumer
les erreurs des autres et être rendu
responsable de tous les maux du pays
sans preuve ni enquête judiciaire alors
là c'est non
la tunisie doit corriger sa situation
revenir à la constitution revenir à ces
institutions avec un gouvernement
légitime un président légitime et un
exécutif légitime à ce moment là nous
pourrons discuter et travailler tous
ensemble si nous ne revenons pas
rapidement à l'état de droit et aux
institutions
les chiffres du pays poursuivront leur
chute dans le rouge
le bureau exécutif en a profité pour
revenir sur l'un des principaux griefs
qui pèsent sur ennahda le dossier des
financements illégaux par des capitaux
étrangers
une référence à un contrat de lobbying
de 30 ils dollars conclu par le parti
islamiste avec l' agence de
communication américaine burton cohn &
wolfe c'était le 29 juillet dernier à
washington ce contrat a rendu public le
3 août 2021 par le département américain
de la justice a attiré l'attention du
poche judiciaire économique et financier
de tunis qui a relevé une infraction à
la législation des changes en l'absence
d'une validation par la banque centrale
de tunis pour ennahdha jamais un contrat
de lobbying a été conclue de près ni de
loin entre le parti et des organisations
étrangères écouter
sur le dossier lobbying je répète que
nous n'avons rien à voir avec cela et ça
a été confirmé par la justice il n'en a
rien été conclus à l'origine par
procuration et rien ne prouve
l'implication du parti ou de son
représentant légal ou de ses dirigeants
ou même ses adhérents pour tout contrat
de lobbying deux heures d'explications
et de présentation de l'état du parti
qui a connu depuis le 25 juillet dernier
date du coup de force du président sayed
une baisse dans les sondages doublée
d'une crise interne ennahda qui n'avait
pas hésité à qualifier le 25 juillet de
coup d'état constitutionnel plaide
néanmoins pour l'ouverture d'un dialogue
national et la reprise des travaux du
parlement seule condition selon lui pour
maintenir les acquis démocratiques de la
révolution 2011 restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons des
nouvelles restrictions du gouvernement
face à la cinquième vague de qu'ovide
les discothèques seront à nouveau
fermées pendant quatre semaines le
protocole sanitaire dans les écoles
primaires passe au niveau 3 c'est-à-dire
masque en intérieur et extérieur pour
tout le monde et dans notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français nous irons à
la rencontre de virginie meyer touché
par le cos vinh long elle a eu pendant
sa première vague et ne s'en est
toujours pas remise
[Musique]
la dette est elle la niche où les
nonistes de la croissance aujourd'hui on
continue à s'endetter et c'est même
devenu un modèle économique et ça depuis
une quinzaine d'années où vous avez le
la croissance qui n'est que la
croissance de la dette en fait est ce
que pour générer plus de profit plus de
richesse créée est ce que c'est bon
d'avoir injecté encore plus en fait
d'argent qui ne m'appartient pas falloir
du remboursement donner la réponse elle
est évidente pour tout ce qu'on a mis le
si peu de résultats mais c'est
pathétique
là ils n'utilisent de la dette pour
manger tous les jours si vous voulez pas
pour investir et donc pour payer les
dépenses publiques de tous les jours de
fonctionnement et à partir de ce moment
là vous savez que vous n'allez pas
générer plus tard de l'argent avec cette
dette
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
c'est ça le point commun entre la france
et la russie c'est le symbiose entre les
civilisations russe française
l'importance du monde artistique c'est
une histoire lumineuse derrière chaque
tableau qu'un une histoire d'amour oui
il derrière un tableau de dali il ya
gala c'est quand même une femme
extraordinaire gala m'a dit je voulais
vladimir signé les hommes comme les
autres signes et les les oeuvres ce
trait modère ce qu'il a raconté ça nous
rappelle aussi le désarroi amoureux de
notre époque c'était une histoire de
modernité je raconte le siècle à travers
l'histoire d'amour et j'ai la chance
extraordinaire avec des moins nantis
être des mois
[Musique]
où
il ya cette dérive du classique basé sur
l'ésotérisme et il ya un autre terrain
de jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire 1 c'est internet on est moins
ceux des jo de mystique moins religieuse
comme on peut on pouvait l'avoir à
110,80 que sur des phénomènes qui vont
concerner la santé ou l'alimentation et
la crise du coc vide à renforcer cette
nouvelle porte d'entrée dans les dérives
sectaires ou des gourous ont plutôt
parlé de vaccination plutôt parler
d'alimentation plutôt parler de guérison
au lieu d'aller directement sur un
terrain qui sera un terrain religieux ou
mystique on retrouve par exemple dans
les dernières manifestations anti
vaccins contre locaux vides certains
éléments qui se rattachent à des
mouvements à tendance sectaire qui
historiquement sont opposés à toute
vaccination
[Musique]
la nouvelle calédonie foule ultime
référendum sur l'indépendance est
maintenue au 12 décembre quel poids
représente aujourd'hui à me moquer
d'elle les indépendantistes dans le
paysage politique en nouvelle calédonie
il ya une progression du oui le peuple
originel concernés par la dépendance il
l'indépendance il d'adventices au camp
représente la france pour la société
calédonienne il n'y a pas eu de n 1
roger d'arte france et c'est à liège
quand même qu'ils ne passent à cet alien
le consumérisme d'assistanat ou ce que
dit j'ai un économisme une économie
assistée sous perfusion si on peut des
statistiques cruel pour trouver plus de
kanaks dans les prisons les hôpitaux
psychiatriques et marge d'une société
que dans la réussite window sociale
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi qui ait des
candidats n'y a pas d'alternative au
sort du politique il est clair que tout
le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu livre
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
les gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire
entre en réanimation toutes les 10
minutes c'est ce qu'affirme ce soir
olivier verront le ministre de la santé
à moins de trois semaines de noël la
france en de nouvelles restrictions face
à la cinquième vague de qu'ovide les
discothèques seront à nouveau fermées
pendant quatre semaines le protocole
sanitaire dans les écoles primaires à ce
niveau 3 c'est-à-dire masque en
intérieur et extérieur pour tout le
monde le gouvernement envisage d'ouvrir
la vaccination à tous les enfants de 5 à
11 ans sur la base du volontariat c'est
aussi d'ici la fin de l'année
et on s'intéressera une conséquence de
ce qu vide le coc vidéo dont on parle
finalement assez peu dans notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français ce soir nous
irons à la ronde virginie meyer qui
souffre depuis plusieurs mois la vie de
cet auxiliaire de puéricultrice a
basculé depuis qu'elle a été frappée par
le corner virus lors de la première
vague elle ne peut plus travailler
depuis un an ne peut plus faire de sport
son témoignage poignant à retrouver dans
quelques instants moule
nous avons de s'intéresser à ces mesures
anti qu'ovide en france et voir ce qui
va changer pour notre quotidien on fait
un petit détour par les états unis à new
york où tous les employés du secteur
privé sont désormais dans l'obligation
d'être vacciné annonce est d'après midi
du maire de la ville qui a franchi ce
pas alors que les cas de variants
omicron ont été détectés dans l'état de
new york pour en parler on retrouve
thomas bonne et notre correspondant aux
états unis bonsoir thomas alors comment
le maire justifie cette décision assez
étonnante pour les états unis thomas
oui alors il faut rappeler que new york
avait été très fortement touché par le
commis de 19 notamment en 2020 avec des
milliers de décès et le maire de la
ville de new york qualifie aujourd'hui à
ces mesures comme une attaque préventive
et audacieuse contre le coc vie 19 alors
que le nombre de cas augmente et qu'il
ya aussi donc l'émergence du variant
omicron il veut absolument dit il éviter
les confinements et les restrictions
dans la plus grande ville américaine
ecoutez-le
au micro des duos ton froid qui nous le
savons présente un véritable défi avec
le co vite sous toutes ses formes ce
sont les fêtes de fin d'année qui
approchent et il se passe beaucoup de
choses ce que nous voyons maintenant
dans d'autres parties du monde et est
vraiment très préoccupant nous voyons
des restrictions revenir un peu partout
nous assistera der confinement regardez
l'allemagne en ce moment une dation si
forte à bien des égards mais la
situation là bas est devenu vraiment
préoccupante alors maintenant ils
rétablissent de nombreuses restrictions
que nous espérions tous être une
histoire passée nous ne pouvons pas
laisser ces restrictions revenir nous ne
pouvons pas avoir de confinement ici à
new york nous devons continuer d'avancer
alors concrètement tous les employés du
secteur privé des entreprises et des
commerces basée à new york devront être
vaccinées d'ici le 27 décembre prochain
autre mesure qui concerne cette fois les
enfants ceux âgés de 5 à 11 ans ils
devront montrer une preuve de
vaccination à partir du 14 décembre pour
pouvoir accéder à certaines activités
extrascolaires alors il faut rappeler
que le 1er novembre dernier déjà le
maire de la ville de new york avait
décidé d'imposer la vaccination
obligatoire pour les employés municipaux
ce qui avait provoqué quelques
mouvements de contestation dans les
rangs des policiers ou encore à des
pompiers on peut dire que new york est
la ville qui va le plus loin en matière
d'obligation de vaccination aux états
unis encore plus loin que les mesures
annoncées au mois de novembre par joe
biden qui je vous le rappelle avec voulu
imposer la vaccination aux employés mais
seulement des entreprises de plus de 100
salariés une mesure qui a été bloqué
suite à une contestation en justice et
d'ailleurs il est aussi le probable que
les mesures annoncées ce lundi par le
maire de la ville de new york soit
contesté en justice merci thomas abonnés
en direct de washington est alors que
les chiffres du comité 19 avoisine les
50 mille quatre quotidiens le
gouvernement a exposé ce soir ces
mesures pour les semaines à venir le
premier ministre a plaidé français est
levé le pied dans les interactions
sociales il a notamment annoncé la
fermeture des discothèques pendant
quatre semaines à partir de ce vendredi
l'ouverture de la vaccination envisagée
pour les 5-11 ans ou encore un
renforcement du protocole sanitaire au
sein des écoles privées r je vous
propose de l'écouter
pour les enfants du primaire nous allons
demander un effort complémentaire
jusqu'aux vacances à compter de jeudi
prochain le port du masque sera
également requis dans les cours de
récréation et les sports collectifs avec
contacts seront restreints à partir de
lundi prochain des conditions de
restauration seront aménagés en lien
avec des élus locaux pour limiter le
plus possible les brassages nous
maintiendrons notre politique de
dépistage systématique de tous les
élèves s'il ya un cas positif dans la
classe et de fermeture de la classe au
bout de trois cas positifs et on parle
rarement de cette conséquence du coc
vide le coc vie gland dans notre
rubrique en pensent les français ce soir
on s'y intéresse nous aidons à la
rencontre de virginie meyer auxiliaire
de puériculture dans un centre
hospitalier sa vie a basculé depuis
qu'elle a été touchée par la maladie
lors de la première vague elle fait
partie de ces français qui n'ont jamais
pu reprendre le cours d'une vie normale
à part après leur contamination
cela fait treize mois qu'elle n'a plus
de salaire et ne travaille pas un sujet
a signé katia technique et sébastien
dufour
je suis à rustenhart près de mulhouse et
je viens à la rencontre de virginie
meyer qui va nous expliquer qu'elle
souffre d'un co bilan depuis mars 2020
bonjour virginie est ce qu'on peut dire
que ça va ou pas vraiment votre vie en
enfer bonjour ben on va dire que la vie
a beaucoup changé et que je suis très
fatigué contrairement à avant où j'étais
plutôt active vous étiez une grande
sportive
oui je faisais de la course à pied qu'à
toi trois quatre fois par semaine et du
coup bah maintenant c'est plus du tout
dans ma maison j'ai appris à la
connaître depuis que je suis malade
parce que auparavant j passé peu de
temps et je suis obligée de me reposer
énormément du coup je sais ce que je
fais alors vous me dites moi comment
tout a commencé tout a démarré dans la
nuit du 24 au 25 mars où j'ai commencé à
sentir une barre assez importants sur le
haut niveau du front et a pas me sentir
bien dans la nuit et puis a commencé à
venir une légère tout avec ensuite une
perte de goût et de doha donc pour moi
c'est s était clair que c'était un coït
par la suite d'autres symptômes sont
arrivés
suite à une rechute que j'ai fait trois
semaines après lors de ma reprise au
travail à un moment vous pouvez même
plus respirer vous avez eu peur oui
alors c'est le seul moment où j'ai
vraiment eu peur
parce que j'avais cette sensation
d'étouffer une oppression au niveau du
thorax
avec un besoin de sentir de l'air frais
est alors de deux moments comme ça à mon
mari a eu assez peur et souhaitait
appeler le samu remous voulait plus
travailler oui j'ai été arrêté parce que
je suis fier du curry culture dans un
établissement sanitaire j'ai d'abord pu
reprendre mon travail en mi temps
thérapeutique pendant quelques mois
jusqu'au 1er octobre date à laquelle où
j'ai eu un malaise sur mon lieu de
travail ce malaise m'a amené aux
urgences et a été considéré comme une
crise d'angoissé au fur et à mesure dans
les choses ont commencé à se compliquer
avec de nouveaux symptômes qui sont
arrivés des démangeaisons au niveau du
haut des bras des démangeaisons à me
gratter au sens à ne plus supporter les
douleurs articulaires et musculaires qui
ne permettait plus de me sécher les
cheveux je devais demander à mes fils de
faire une grosse grosse fatigue qui
m'obligeait à dormir plusieurs fois par
jour jusqu'à 4 sieste parfois en plus de
la nuit plaint de troubles que ce soit à
digestif cognitif
neurologiques et tout ça pendant
longtemps on n'a pas été objective et
par des résultats médicaux on parle
d'errance médicale parce qu'on fait en
ce qui concerne locaux vides long la
médecine apprend en même temps que nous
encore aujourd'hui vous avez eu la
chance d'avoir un médecin qui vous a
très bien suivi parce que c'était
suffisant vu l'importance de vos
symptômes alors non ce n'était pas
suffisant et d'ailleurs il avec grande
honnêteté
dit qu'ils ne savaient plus quoi faire
du coup toujours on attend en ayant
discuté avec lui auparavant j'ai pu
prendre rendez vous chez les
spécialistes
si vous voulez on peut aller voir j'ai
écrit tout un dossier qui est bien épais
on pourra pousser bout si ces coups tous
ces onglets alors tous ces anglais c'est
les différents médecins différents
spécialistes que j'ai pu rencontrer
depuis du pull mois d'octobre autant un
urologue qu un qui n'est qu'une
orthoptistes qu'un qui investit muller
une pneumologue et cetera cardiologue
alors c'est lié au nom des résultats est
ce que dans un premier temps déjà le
fait qu'ils aient des résultats c'est un
sentiment de soulagement parce que je
m'en moque ou dit que c'était
psychologique maintenant ce que j'ai
c'est un déficit d'une ère vestibulaire
qui est tellement important que ça me
déclenché des vertiges des malaises et
c'est quelque chose que je vais essayer
de rééduquer mais a priori ça ne se
refera pas
j'ai également ce qu'on n'a pas une
hypertrophie la base de la langue dont
c'est cette sensation d'avoir mal dans
la gorge et que ce soit assez gros et
c'est dérangeant à la parole quand je
mange ou l'art de fatigue le parcours du
combattant oui c'est un parcours du
combattant parce qu'il faut se faire
reconnaître
et c'est un petit peu le combat je
dirais que je mène aujourd'hui avec un
collectif qui s'appelle actions comme il
y en avait plus travaillé comment ça se
gère tout ça alors c'est très compliqué
puisque comme n'ya pas de reconnaissance
à aucun niveau même au niveau des
assurances pour les prises en charge
mais j'ai grand espoir que lors de
l'assemblée nationale cette loi sur la
reconnaissance j'ai coville l'on soit
acceptée et que tout se débloque vous
êtes fatigué physiquement à ce que vous
êtes fatigué un peu moralement de tout
ça oui parce que ça fait des mois que je
me bats contre quelque chose qui n'est
pas forcément visible non plus donc
forcément ça pose des questions aussi
parfois des personnes de l'entourage si
cette expérience malheureuse scoville
long ça vous laisse car l'impression
quand j'ai eu un moment donné une
impression d'abandon et puis finalement
non j'ai trouvé j'ai retrouvé mes
priorités pour moi beaucoup de choses
ont changé il y avait avant et puis
orales après qu vide
alors comment endiguer cette cinquième
vague en france et ses conséquences
parfois dramatiques quand même constaté
nouvelle série de mesures annoncées par
le gouvernement ce soir est elle
vraiment suffisant pour mettre fin à la
propagation les cours d'école désormais
lieu de contamination place au
décryptage
[Musique]
et avec moi pour en parler ce soir bruno
me garbade chef du service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris bonsoir
de te remercie d'être avec nous à nos
côtés franck delvaux restaurateurs co
président de l'umih paris-ile-de-france
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sans que
delvaux enfin nicolas l'on dit
coordinateur du collectif parents
atterré bonsoir à vous également merci
d'être là une petite réaction avant
évidemment de parler un de ces nouvelles
mesures annoncées par olivier ferrand et
jean castex ce soir une réaction sur ce
témoignage assez poignant quand on a vu
de virginie meyer on parle assez peu
ducobu dont vous nous avez un petit peu
par les uns d'ailleurs de cela docteur
de temps en temps c'est quand même
fréquence ce type de deux symptômes ça
fait un an que cette femme qui était
sportive ne peut plus courir qu'elle est
fatiguée qu'elle ne peut plus travailler
alors qu'on estime à peu près 10% des
personnes qui ont fait la queue vide par
une infection naturelles auront des
symptômes qui vont persister au-delà du
troisième mois alors on sait pas il n'y
a pas de facteur qui prédisent le risque
c'est une personne qui fait réellement
l'infection il faut à nouveau le
rappeler sont des personnes qui font une
infection
mineurs c'est pas des personnes qui
viennent en rénovation eux qui auront
devrait complications et séquelles qui
sont attribués à la gravité de leur
maladie ici en fait très probablement à
l'occasion de cette infection par le sar
skov 2 il va y avoir une certaine
inflammation de certaines structures
cérébrales qui vont être responsable de
symptômes diverses c'est pourquoi le
tableau est très polymorphe d'ailleurs
certains le mettant en cause en dix ans
c'est plutôt psychosomatique mais des
explorations extrêmement sérieuses
montrent des éléments objectifs
d'atteinte de structures neurologique
centrale à l'origine de ces symptômes
heureusement beaucoup de ces symptômes
sont spontanément régressif avec le
temps et il se pourrait même que la
vaccination que l'on fait après avoir
été infectés accélère cette réversion
on va parler maintenant évidemment de
ces restrictions on a entendu les deux
ministres ce soir face à cette
résurgence en tout cas voici donc un
aperçu des annonces du gouvernement les
plus de 65 ans qui pourront accéder aux
rappels de vaccins sans rendez-vous
fermeture des discothèques pendant
quatre semaines l'ouverture de la
vaccination visage et pour tous les
enfants de 5 à 11 ans on va les détails
et avec vous messieurs merritt tout
d'abord une question encore au dr meijer
ban cette vaccination ouverts aux plus
de 65 ans ont rendez vous ça va changer
quelque chose selon vous parce qu'on en
parle tout le temps de ces personnes
âgées qu'on ne vient pas chercher sur
dans leur maison pour venir se faire
vacciner ce que cela ça va changer
c'était la bonne mesure ce soir alors on
va discuter tout à l'heure mais le
gouvernement a pris finalement très peu
de mesures restrictives a fait beaucoup
de pédagogie et souhaite responsabiliser
la population en termes de respect des
mesures barrières mais il a choisi quand
même deux armes essentielles la première
c'est la vaccination des enfants on en
reparlera mais aussi cette dose de
rappels chez tous les adultes à partir
du cinquième mois après la double dose
alors on va dire la diminution de
protection avec le temps à partir de la
double vaccination
est atteint la totalité des personnes
mais néanmoins cette protection devient
plus problématique chez les personnes
les plus âgées les plus fragiles avec
des comorbidités il est donc tout à fait
logique de permettre aux personnes de
plus de 65 ans de bénéficier de cette
dose de rappel le plus rapidement
possible car lorsqu'on regarde les
patients doublement vaccinés qui sont
admis à l'hôpital ou en rénovation c'est
essentiellement des personnes âgées ou
immunodéprimées
alors on va regarder une première
réaction à celle de marine le pen
forcément dans l'opposition et pas
forcément contente on s'en doute à côté
de la plaque dit elle jean castex
préfère punir des enfants innocents en
imposant le masque en extérieur à
l'école plutôt que mettre en place des
bus purificateurs d'air en des tests
gratuits pour tous sont encore réintégré
les 1000 les 15000 soignants suspendu
alors il est vrai que que beaucoup de
mesures concerne nos enfants un nicolas
l'andi a notamment le port du masque ça
y est on s'y retrouve aussi à
l'extérieur à nos bambins avec le masque
sur la bouche on parlera aussi de la
vaccination visage et pour tous les
enfants de 5 à 11 ans et ce à partir du
20 décembre sont la base du volontariat
pour les plus fragiles ça sera ouvert
évidemment en priorité nicolas landi une
réaction sur ces mesures qui concernent
principalement les enfants ce soir
non moi je voulais dire j'avais été
particulièrement touché par le
témoignage de la personne touchée par un
kobe de long
on espère sa pompe son compteur
établissement c'est important de dire
parce que aujourd'hui il ya d'autres
personnes qui sont touchées par d'autres
formes de co vision ce sont les encens
le comme il est long très long pour les
enfants je vous rappelle que on les
prive presque totalement de l'odorat
pendant dix heures par jour quand ils
sont masqués hyper de l'acuité visuelle
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal à
mettre leurs lunettes donc va pas voir
leur correction visuelle ils ont eu
aussi des troubles cognitifs parce que à
quand pour leur apprendre à lire et à
écrire c'est très difficile ils ne
lisent pas sur les lèvres de leurs
enseignants sur les ailes de leurs
camarades les moyens de communication
non verbale bas il en soit au sifflet
pour l'essentiel leur psychisme et
atteint tout ça s'est avéré donc les
effets du comme ils sont très très long
pour les enfants et donc pas cette
mesure pour nous elle est assez loufoque
on les a remarqués vous souvenez que 45%
des départements
avaient levé l'obligation du masque
entre octobre et novembre de novembre on
a dû les remet à ce qu'est et puis là il
ya effectivement une augmentation forte
des taux de contamination chez les
petits en leur ne discute pas parce que
l'on fait énormément tech et les petits
et beaucoup moins chez les adultes
puisque la team c'est payant
et et malgré le masque et bien ces taux
augmente beaucoup donc bah il avait plus
que le moment la récré pour respirer
basse et fils est fichue 1
alors qu'on sait parfaitement que la
probabilité d'attraper les coville à
l'extérieur est divisé par 20 par
rapport à l'intérieur donc ça c'est la
première mesure place des mesures qui va
venir très vite c'est on va sans doute
nous dire que la vaccination des petits
est obligatoire et allons-y donc alors
que c'est la responsabilité des parents
de décider de quelle manière ils vont
protéger leurs enfants je ne vois pas
quel est l'intérêt de faire vacciner les
p'tiots peu oui encore une consternation
encore une fois il faut montrer un
activisme alors que ben lapointe délit
cours on est proche du pic de 2020 on
est on a quand tu vas bientôt se
rapprocher des pics de 2002 2020 avril
2020 on a cette chance qu'il ya beaucoup
moins de morts par contre parce que
effectivement
les vaccins levac sens où montré une
efficacité a quand même passé aussi la
parole aux autres invités on a bien en
tout cas compris merci de votre clarté
bruno megaman
voilà on entende ce parent un petit peu
voire désole de voir encore les enfants
c'est vrai est entre guillemets ciblés
par ces mesures est ce bien nécessaire
une fois encore beaucoup de français
pensent que les plus fragiles ne sont
pas les enfants ça veut dire quoi que
eudes doivent trinquer pour protéger les
autres et notamment les non vaccinés
alors on va dire monsieur a bien
souligné que les enfants peuvent être
atteints par la coved 19 avec parfois
des ennuis assez important d'abord vous
voyez beaucoup alors moi je ne m'occupe
que d'adultes donc
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est le la
classe d'âge où circule le plus fort
taux de
2,2 de virus quasiment le double de
l'incidence dans la population générale
l'institut pasteur avait prédit que 50%
des contaminations au cours de cette
vague se feront chez les enfants
pourquoi parce que le virus circule
préférentiellement celle et les
personnes non vaccinées et là on a une
classe d'âge entière
qui est pas du tout vacciner peu
immunisés et donc évidemment c'est le
terreau favori de circulation du virus
donc de fait effectivement il faut être
un peu plus prudent alors je suis
d'accord que le masque dans la cour de
récréation c'est pas le moyen radical
pour lui tirer dessus par contre je
pense que la vaccination sera très utile
car il n'y a aucune raison qu'elle ne
qu'elle soit mal toléré il n'y a aucune
raison qu'elle soit à qu'elle
s'accompagne d'effets secondaires plus
important que chez les adultes à
l'inversé elle est parfaitement efficace
elle permettra de réduire la circulation
du virus dans cette classe d'âge est de
permettre un bénéfice direct aux enfants
c'est ça le plus important c'est ce qu'a
expliqué monsieur c'est à dire ils ne
tomberont pas malade il ne développeront
pas de kobe de long ils n'auront pas de
syndrome inflammatoire important et
surtout ils pourront suivre une
scolarité normale et ne pas servir de
vecteur de transmission du virus à des
adultes de leur entourage plus fragile
plus âgés éventuellement avec
immunosuppression et donc c'est ainsi
qu'on va pouvoir maîtriser la
circulation du virus alors je vais me
tourner vers vous quand même franck
delvaux un co président de l'umih paris
ile de france on n'a pas parlé de
restaurant pour une fois c'est ce que
craignaient les restaurateurs évidemment
la sphère de la jauge apparemment ça ça
restera ainsi en revanche fermeture des
discothèques ça c'est un petit peu le
coup dur on imagine pour les
discothèques yvon refermer encore une
fois pendant quatre semaines la réaction
en tout cas sur ces mesures globalement
et effectivement c'est compliqué pour
nos amis des discothèques mais aussi
très compliqué pour les restaurants
parce qu'effectivement pas de jauge pour
les restaurants mais si une fermeture
déguisée des restaurants également des
bars et des hôtels puisqu'on nous dit
repassons télétravail trois jours par
semaine plus de moments festifs dans les
entreprises plus de réunions en
présentiel ont relevé l'existence yale
on sait que le mois de décembre est un
mois propice dans nos établissements
ad-pa dépôt à d ida distinctive à des
réunions donc là on enlève tout ça donc
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que 70 %
des restaurateurs ont des cascade
d'annulations les hôtels également aux
45 % d'annulations de chambre donc pour
nous c'est une fermeture déguisée de
nous teaser nous procèderons pardonnez
moi parce que je ne vais pas vous mentir
j'étais aussi à l'antenne quand j'ai eu
ces annonces il n'y a pas de réelle
contrainte c'est une limitation que sous
la forme d'un d'un conseil n'est ce pas
d'éviter les interactions sociales c'est
une fermeture ce qui me fermeture
déguisée parce qu'en fait je peux vous
dire que depuis quatre jours nous avons
des casquettes d'adulation dans nos
établissements donc on demande la
reprise du quoi qu'il en coûte et de
nouveau d'avoir des êtres dans nos
établissements parce que là c'est une
formule sans diviser on dit aux gens ne
lis pas dans les restaurants n'allez pas
dans les bars c'est dangereux vous
pouvez attraper le comité donc certes on
peut le comprendre pour pour la pour des
mesures sanitaires pour la santé du pays
mais à côté de ça pour mettre en place
le quoi qu'il en coûte alors docteur il
ya eu plusieurs
réactions évidemment sur cette fermeture
des discothèques pour le président de
l'umih un l'homologue de notre ami
monsieur delvaux illumin8 cette fois la
fermeture des discothèques ne changera
rien car les gens vont se trouver dans
les bars pour mathieu lebrun g en
discothèque avec ou sans nous la
jeunesse fera la fête et va se
contaminer tout autant et enfin stéphane
manigold à un président du groupe et
clore sans une pointe de sociétés de
boîte de nuit par dont la santé est
primordiale mais la santé des chefs
d'entreprise est aussi importante sur
ces deux remarques ça sert à rien parce
que les gens vont aller faire la fête
ailleurs c'est pas vraiment faux une
jeunesse qui a été muselé pendant deux
ans on va pas les arrêter là non vous
avez raison donc ce n'est pas
l'essentiel des mesures l'essentiel à
nouveau c'est la vaccination c'est à
dire la troisième dos et la totalité des
adultes et la vaccination des enfants
qui doit débuter le plus rapidement
possible c'est ça les mesures
importantes en termes de santé publique
mais à côté de ça il ya les mesures
barrières et je crois que le
gouvernement essentiellement de table
sur la pédagogie la responsabilisation
mais il est vrai qu'il faut donner un
signal quand même que malheureusement
nous sommes dans une période difficile
et c'est vrai que on sait que
malheureusement la nuit dans des
établissements où les gens s'entassent
ou peut-être le système d'aération n'est
pas optimale ou surtout les gens
consomment de l'alcool et donc perdre un
peu le sens réel des choses et bien il y
à des contaminations il y a des
attitude à risque et de fait cette
décision était prise mais à nouveau je
ne crois pas que ce soit l'essentiel des
mesures quand vous entendez franck
delvaux nous dire voilà annonce une
catastrophe parce que c'est vrai qu'on
dissuader les gens de se réunir d'oran
dans les endroits publics les
restaurants - de convivialité pour noël
ça me semble être vraiment nécessaire
parce qu'on nous dit voilà on nous
pousse à la vaccination et ça suffit
toujours pas je suis d'accord
effectivement on va dire on vit une
période difficile maintenant les
restaurants peuvent fonctionner les 6
lits on va dire les les consignes
sanitaires habituels sont bien
appliquées le risque d'être contaminé
est quand même faible
malgré tout effectivement si on laissait
les choses progresser sans contrôle eh
bien on risquerait d'avoir un
effondrement de l'hôpital incapables de
prendre en charge les patients et donc
de fait d'imposer un confinement strict
et c'est ce qu'on veut éviter par des
mesures de prévention qui permettraient
d'éviter cette situation malgré tout il
faut dire que très clairement l'épidémie
va atteindre son pic lac de la cinquième
vague d'ici une quinzaine de jours il ya
un ralentissement de la vitesse de
progression de l'épidémie et donc ces
mesures qui sont pas si restrictif de sa
devront accompagner cette régression de
l'épidémie et on l'espère pas pour un
plateau haut parce que c'est ça le
problème c'est que si l'épidémie
régressé vicomte se resituer sur un
plateau coup comme l'année passée eh
bien on risquerait cette fois-ci de
noyer l'hôpital qui n'a plus les moyens
de faire face à l'afflux de patients
ayant lakovic 19 nicolas lundi on arrive
bientôt à la fin de notre débat une
mesure qui a changé enfin c'est pas
d'hier sa dette de quelques jours déjà
on ne ferme plus les classes son premier
4 qu'ovide on teste et on isole ceux qui
sont positifs en tant que parent votre
réaction est là dessus
je suis pas du tout contre que d'avancer
essentiel que les classes restent
ouverts ensuite effectivement on lutte
on participe à la lutte contre la
propagation du virus et je peux pas
laisser dire que ce sont les enfants qui
contamine les adultes ça c'est pas
possible
aujourd'hui c'est que le vaccin ne
protège pas contre la contamination est
ce qui protège le mieux contre la
contamination malheureusement c'est
d'être touchés par le virus et
aujourd'hui quand vous avez 50 mille
personnes par jour qui sont touchés vous
avez aussi des gens qui du coup seront
viabilisés c'est pas n'importe quoi que
de dire ça ça a été des stratégies
conscient par exemple de pays comme la
suède et aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas toute
cette population d'enfants qui souffrent
énormément
du fait de mesures sanitaires
qui ne sont pas utiles pour eux en tout
cas les petits seins je parle pas des
adolescents la discussion est différente
et pour les petits ce n'est pas utile
pour eux ils ne sont pas malades depuis
le début de la pandémie il ya eu trois
enfants décédés et pau ville avec de la
comorbidité donc voilà toutes ces
mesures prises rencontre des enfants ce
n'est pas dans leur intérêt il faut très
vite très vite leur permet de revivre
normalement si nous d'un point de vue
sociétal serait une catastrophe ça l'est
déjà puis franck devant le mot de la fin
pour pour vous aujourd'hui dans quel
état d'esprit êtes vous on l'a compris
inquiet vous demander la poursuite du
quoi qu'il en coûte il n'empêche son
sens justement que les français ressorte
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on voit dans les
rues des grandes villes en tout cas pour
paris on a vu des stations ski également
se remplir à nouveau comment vous sentez
les prochaines semaines de votre côté
c'est un petit passage difficile et ça
ira mieux après où les français en
râlant tard
non les fonctions peur on leur fait peur
je peux vous dire que je vous le redis
on a d un taux d'annulation
extraordinaire depuis quelques jours et
ça va s'amplifier dès demain donc
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
venez au restaurant venez quand même au
restaurant parce qu'on a un protocole
salita très strictes je rappelle que
notre personnel est également vaccinés
on contrôler les passes sanitaires mais
à côté de ça il faut que le gouvernement
assume ces mesures et puis remettant
vous remettre en fonction le crois qu'il
en coûte pour les hôtels les restaurants
et les bars merci beaucoup à tous les 3
bruno meyer vannes nicolas landi nick
franck pardon delvaux merci d'avoir été
avec nous pour réagir aux annonces donc
de ce soir rester avec nous ne restez
pas avec nous d'ailleurs rendez vous
demain c'est déjà fini à 20h n'oubliez
pas de réagir sur notre compte
télégramme berthet français d'actualité
continue toute la soirée
[Musique]
la nouvelle calédonie fauves ultime
référendum sur l'indépendance est
maintenue au 12 décembre quel poids
représente aujourd'hui à une moc ademe
les indépendantistes dans le paysage
politique en nouvelle calédonie qu il ya
une progression du oui le peuple
originel concernés par la dépendance il
l'indépendance files d'attentes saut
quand on représente la france pour la
société calédonienne il n'y a pas eu de
haine ou un rejet de la france c'est à
liège quand même qui n'est pas ça c'est
un lien de consumérisme d'assistanat ou
ce que dit j'ai un économiste une
économie assistée sous perfusion si on
fait des statistiques cruel pour vous
retrouver plus de canal dans les prisons
pour les hôpitaux psychiatriques ou
marcher une société que dans la réussite
au niveau social